you know there is a food that is way
worse
than sugar check this out and i'm going
to put all the research down below this
is the chart showing all of the factors
that can shorten your life okay it can
cause
you dying okay and so at the very top of
the list we have severe obesity can
increase your risk of
dying by 93 okay then we have heavy
smoking all right 80
and then look at what we have right here
vegetable oils 62
this is the one that is worse than sugar
now as we come down below vegetable oils
we have physical activity which is 48
then heavy drinking 41
moderate smoking which is 30
and only 13 for excessive sugar
consumption and then we have processed
meat 11
air pollution 11
red meat which i disagree with because
they haven't done any studies comparing
grass fed versus grain fed
and then sodium which is three percent
which they haven't probably also
compared uh relative ratios of
potassium okay but i just wanted to show
you this chart so you can see where
vegetable oils are in relationship to
everything else an average person in
america consumes 80 grams
of vegetable oils now vegetable oils
sound really great it's oil from
vegetables i mean there's not a lot of
oil in vegetables and that's why it's
really not vegetable oil it's seed oil
it's legume oil it is grain oil and by
the way it takes a lot of grain and and
seeds to make just a little bit of
oil but an average person consumes 80
grams of vegetable oil per day that's
six tablespoons that comes out to 720
calories
which is about 32
of an average person's total calories so
a third of our diet
is
vegetable oils and the introduction of
vegetable oils into our diet to replace
saturated fats it was probably the
biggest
change in the last 50 years and you can
also deduct from these numbers some
other things like every 5
increase in daily calories from
vegetable oils
correlates
to smoking about seven cigarettes per
day
all right vegetables seed oil grain oil
legume oil
not like celery oil or broccoli oil or
salad oil okay
but vegetable sounds a lot better okay
on this next slide i have a few more
points
but i'm trying to hit home the
importance of avoiding vegetable oils
because 30 of all of our calories
come from these oils right here we're
talking about the soy oil corn oil
canola cottonseed peanut oil sunflower
oil and safflower oil i mean if you look
at the label on hummus for example they
don't use olive oil anymore they use soy
sometimes they might use sunflower oil
so the problem with these vegetable oils
extremely
pro-inflammatory they're going to create
a lot of inflammation especially
if they're fried okay you heat them so
you go to the restaurant you get some
hors d'oeuvres usually fried with either
corn oil canola or soy oil and so
restaurants are the biggest culprit i
can't tell you how many times i go to a
restaurant i leave just not feeling very
good like i might have like this weird
symptom in the back of my throat i feel
bloated so you really don't know what
you're always getting when you actually
go to dinner so just make sure you read
the labels ask the waiter or waitress
what type of oils do you use okay and
just order basic things that you know
they're not going to put the oil in
because these things add up
of the population in the u.s consume
fast food on a daily basis so you can
only imagine how much omega-6
that's accumulating in their body and
what it's doing to the arteries what
it's doing to the pancreas what it's
doing to their brain and one interesting
study which i'll put down below
there is an increase by 62 percent death
rate of all-cause mortality
compared to consuming saturated fats so
there's been a huge push to get everyone
away from saturated fats to the
unsaturated fats which is a huge huge
mistake
saturated fats are very very stable with
cooking they can withstand high heats
you don't have the oxidation you know
the
the creating of the free radicals when
you use saturated fats especially
when you're frying foods and i don't
even talk about reheating at restaurants
like how often do you think they change
the oil
it might be weeks to months so you're
getting these omega-6 oils that are
reheated over and over and over again
they might filter out some of the debris
and some of the burnt particles
but that's a tremendous amount of
oxidation
all right next point only severe obesity
and heavy smoking are more deadly than
vegetable oils
on the chart i mean that just blows my
mind i mean sugar if we compare it to
vegetable oils it's not even in the same
ballpark as far as what vegetable oils
do to the body
in another study there was an 82
increase risk of cancer which makes
sense because when you put these
products in the body that are so
pro-inflammatory you're creating damage
in the dna and also cancer tends to
follow in areas of inflammation they
tend to migrate in areas where you have
inflammation so only use
olive oil butter yi lard talo or coconut
oil
when you're cooking
and in your food now since we're on the
topic of saturated fats if you haven't
seen my video on butter i put that up
right here check it out